as many of you know with the corona
virus outbreak still very much underway
there's a huge number of students who
are left to learn remotely from home
whether that means doing distance
classes over videoconference or trying
to find resources like Khan Academy and
brilliant to learn online so one thing
that I wanted to do in the next coming
weeks which is very different for me on
this channel is to do some live streamed
lectures specifically targeted at high
school students with each lecture I want
to cover something that's a standard
high school topic that most high
schoolers will be expected to learn but
at the same time to have some kind of
intriguing angle on it that's a little
bit different from what most people
might have seen just so that if you
aren't a high school student and you're
someone like me there's still something
interesting about it for example the
very first lesson is going to be on a
simpler version of the quadratic formula
and while I was putting together this
lesson I honestly felt a little bit mad
that this isn't the way that I learned
things when I was in high school so if
you can get that same feeling I'm gonna
call that mission success one thing I'm
particularly excited about is a little
piece of technology that two good
friends of mine who I used to work at
Khan Academy with have been working on
which I think should make the dynamic
between the audience and the progression
of the lecture feel a little bit more
tight than it usually does in some kind
of livestream situation I don't want to
say anything more I would just say show
up be prepared to answer some questions
and to ask questions to my goal is for
to feel as much like a real class as
possible most of the dynamic is just
going to be you and me talking through
problems on a piece of paper which even
though I love to visualize stuff and put
out animations and that's kind of what
the whole channel is about to be honest
I think just working through things on
paper feels more like what actual math
is to me and what the process of finding
new ideas and coming to terms with them
yourself
looks like the tentative plan right now
is to do every Friday and Tuesday at
noon pacific time but if anything
changes on that you'll see the schedule
on the banner of the channel so tune in
I hope to see you there and be prepared
to do some math
[Music]
you
[Music]